Okay, this is Jason.
I'm doing a cold open.
I'm real snacky.
It's carbohydrates.
They're crunchy.
They're salty.
They're not good for me.
But man, it feels good.
Doesn't it feel good, gang,
to do a nice, crunchy, salty snack?
Or do you like the gooey, sweet ones?
I don't know.
Maybe a combo of both is great, right?
But what do you start with?
Which do you end with?
What do you put in between?
I know what you put in between.
and you put in a nice big, fat, well-cooked episode of Smartless.
Numb-Num-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-W.
Welcome to SmartLus.
Smart.
Stress.
You know, guys, I can't have the stress.
I lost my voice, and it's just now come back a little bit.
I still have a little brand of car.
Are you screaming at people on set?
Is it from the Knicks games?
Or is you screaming at people on set again?
I think it was, it was a, it was a.
I want my chair over here.
My chair.
It was, I think it was a cold
or it might have been allergies.
No.
I mean, yeah.
By yourself?
It started, yeah.
It started in my throat
and it went to my nose
and then it landed on my vocal cords.
You're a little,
Jason's a little fragile.
I feel like this is the first time
we're meeting the real J.B. right now.
And I was a little frazzled
getting to Mike today
because that's what we call it, right?
Getting to Mike.
Because I wanted to have my teeth brushed
for you.
Do you guys brush your teeth for me?
Of course, always.
No, not me.
You don't.
Don't you, bro, look at his teeth.
Did you sleep with a whitener on too long last night?
No, I went to the, look at that.
I went to the dentist yesterday, and he's like, I don't wipe my teeth.
How about that?
And you smoke.
And you drink coffee.
I know.
And you self-tan.
I thought, don't self-tan.
That's the one where don't make me mad.
You and Kimmel.
Nobody loves hitting me.
me my tan more than Molly.
Wait, what self-tan mean?
You just lays out.
That's like a cream.
But where do you find the time and how is it always so even, Mr. Trump?
Well, you know, you know what I do every day.
I do my walk every day.
And so that's like an hour.
I don't talk to me like I'm fucking watching you doing your fucking heavy hands and shit.
You know what my roots are your Velcro ankle weights.
You know my room too.
Is it?
With my weight best.
Somebody took a picture of me with my hair.
weight vest yesterday on Loma Vye.
Oh, really?
I got to see that.
But Will, I spend a lot of time when I'm not working on the golf course, as we're aware.
What?
That's five hours of sun exposure, and I wear 100.
So you're saying you're 20-minute...
I don't wear.
Okay, that's what it is.
A, and B, I don't wear a bucket hat.
Right.
So you wear no sun protection whatsoever.
You're kind of bragging about that right now to get yourself that nice color,
but you're giving yourself fucking cancer.
I'm not, first of all,
fucking cool it.
It's early for me to die, okay?
I've had skin cancer already.
I had something shaved off my eye.
Remember that?
Yeah, I do.
Go in there and got it all scraped off.
I get checked.
I have a friend of mine,
and she's been giving me a lot of shit
about sunscreen lately.
Are these checks that you pay for,
or is it,
you say a friend?
Like a close friend of mine.
Does she check for ticks
at the same time and all those tough to find spots.
We've found another one.
She just squeezes it out.
Like a zip.
You're covered in ticks.
I found a couple of leeches too.
I'm like, so?
They have to remove the poison.
The ticks and the tick.
Oh my gosh.
So wait, so you've got a, yeah, now you're getting into a sweat
because you're thinking about all the possible risks you're taking.
I've also had four coffees today.
so having a coffee sweat.
Yeah.
You know, we were at dinner the other night, J.B., you were missed.
I know.
You were missed.
And Jen brought a photo up from our big family trip
from a few years back where we went with all the kids and everything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
God, I love that, too.
And there was a photo of all of us,
and then my head sticking out in the back.
Remember how ten I was?
And my hair is sticking up.
And then I've got zinc on my lips,
and I look like a crazy person, right, John?
I looked like that.
We passed around the back.
photo and everybody had something to say about it and I've never seen it before I was like what is I look like I look like you look like you look like a predator like
like you guys came to the island and found me there like I'd laid out you know I'd written in the sand sOS we have to go back there I know back guys it'd be fun to go now with the kids a little bit older before how's it night it's it's fun being back for the weekend yeah very nice to be back for the weekend yeah I'm going to your Q&A jay at tomorrow at Netflix because I want to I know that you're doing a Q&A session right hey what
What are you doing there?
I'm just going to go, because I want to ask you questions about directing and stuff.
I know you're getting a good thing.
And so I got an email from Netflix about it.
Like, come join us.
I'm like, oh, I'm coming.
Wear the zinc on your nose so that when you pulled your hand out.
I'm going to put a fake mustache and a hat.
And then I'm going to sit in the back.
And I'm going, I've got a question.
No, you should play the crazy Italian guy from our podcast.
Yeah.
I love a black rabbit.
What is your, these brothers are crazy.
You're unheed.
I can't believe they sent you an invite.
No, actually, a different friend of mine got an email about it,
and they sent it to me.
And I was like, oh, fucking send me that.
I want to go.
I want to go show up and crash.
How good.
And then, you know what?
I did have the thought.
I was like, if I did it, then I make it about me.
And I'm not going to go and do that.
No, why do that?
Please, please, please, do it enough.
There's so many people listening right now who are nodding going.
I know.
You do make it about you shut up.
We hate your stupid stories.
But what about, like, yeah, so I'm here this weekend.
to do these interviews and stuff for DTF and for Black Rabbit and stuff.
And it's all talking.
It's all talking.
You're going to make it.
Including this podcast.
And I was looking at literally 36 hours ago, I couldn't, I couldn't.
Everything was like this.
I couldn't make a set.
And I was like, oh, my God, I've got like five days of work ahead of me that's just talking.
Luckily, I got a little prednisone in me and an antipot.
Yeah, good.
You know what?
I was talking to our buddy who's doing.
dog day afternoon, not John Brunthal,
but I was talking to, you guys know John Ortiz
is the best, he's a great actor
and he's a good buddy mine.
And he is on Broadway right now,
and he has a really bad cold,
and it's a night, he's like,
it's a nightmare scenario.
I almost called you, Sean,
because I knew you'd probably have some,
like, fancy Broadway doctor
that knows how to deal with vocal,
vocal stuff.
Always, I have, too,
the best.
Boots, boots, I'll text you.
Boots.
Boots, no.
Wait, wait, is that,
is that, wait, Sean,
are you getting rid of peasant?
battles and co-ing with boots right now he's boots right now he's boots oh boots mcgee yeah and boots
yeah because of a boot on um but uh speaking of some's got a point that he wants to make i saw him
who are you looking at off camera who's giving you the cue to go into it is this guy no nobody me it's
i'm looking at all of you no we have to go because our guest is super famous and she has to work
oh sorry okay yes here we go here we go so i should have got dressed up i meanwhile got undressed
put your sleeves back on it i'm going to put a nice apache me there um
Oh, guys, my guest today, who I love and I live for,
grew up in Castle Hill, New York,
the middle of three sisters in an apartment.
Andrew Martin.
So small, they all shared a bed.
There was always music in the house
with constant reenactments of West Side Story.
I could do the whole thing with her.
Chenoweth.
But her parents still hoped she'd become a lawyer.
Instead, she left college to pursue dance full-time,
left home and ended up sleeping in a Manhattan dance studio.
Somewhere along the way,
she taught Carrie Washington how to dance.
I can't wait to ask.
about that. Then she became the first Latina actress ever paid a million dollars for a movie role.
Bruno Marino.
Briefly been on this podcast before, it's the beautiful, multi-talented and unstoppable.
Jennifer Lopez.
Yes!
The way.
Willie got it.
Very nice.
It's for you a few.
No, when you said briefly, and then I remember you briefly on, yes.
I was so close with Andrew Martin. God damn it.
So close.
Oh, my God.
Jen, what are you drinking?
Hi there.
A little cappuccino.
Oh, nice.
What do you go with for the milk on that?
Are we almond?
Are we oats?
I'm traditional.
I like a 2% milk.
I know everybody's with fancy oats and almonds and soy.
Cow milk all the way.
Jason, Jason responds to that, you beta?
I know, but I feel, I got word from one of those doctors back in the day that I'm lactose intolerant or bad with the dairy or something like that.
And so I've just never had like cow milk since it.
Plus, I did see a documentary once where they said the very disgusting fact,
which is humans are the only species that drink the milk of another animal.
I don't care.
That like, it is weird, isn't it?
It is weird.
I'm the same way.
I don't care.
I know.
You drink full, tall glasses of milk, Sean.
I don't care.
I know.
And it tastes so good.
It tastes so good.
Plus, but Jennifer Lopez is always working out and exercising.
and staying in good health so she can have milk in her coffee.
I try.
Right?
Well, not about that.
It's not about that.
It's not a bad health choice.
But I mean, you know, if you're going to do it, you kind of have to balance it.
Says Jennifer Lopez.
She's Dr. Ding Dong over there.
You look very, very healthy.
Thank you.
Jen, thank you for doing this.
I'm so excited you're here.
This is a long time coming from me.
You've been on my list since we started.
Oh, you're sweet.
Wow, this is exciting.
It's true.
And I know we kind of know each other.
and I love you too.
Do you?
Yes, we work together many times over the years.
Will and Grace.
And the Will and Grace.
And something else, too.
I can't remember what.
Did we?
I think so.
You know what I realized?
I'm so bad that, you know,
you get to a point where you've done so much with so many people.
And people are like, we did that.
Like the other day, don't hate me.
I was watching Monster-in-law.
Oh, my God.
And I forgot you were in.
You are like, what?
I'm going to do that podcast.
No, no, because it was just so long ago.
I mean, I don't want to say how many years ago it was, but it was so long ago.
Wasn't that during the rest of development, Willie?
You did that?
It was 21 years ago.
It was the summer of 2005.
21 years ago.
You know, Jennifer, as I'm admiring your beautiful printer in the background there,
I then noticed that, Sean, you've moved the award.
Didn't you have an award behind you last week?
Yes, because you made fun of me.
And I made funny, you moved it.
Yeah, I did.
But it's just right there, both of them.
But what about how, how, how.
Jen keeps it real.
She's got a fucking printer in the bed right of her frame.
That's a bizhub.
I'm in a hotel.
You are?
Where?
In New York?
I was here for the upfront.
So I'm just here.
No, but you know,
you know,
people like stack their awards behind them
when they do zooms?
Yeah, I do.
Yeah.
No, you don't.
But I, in my office at home,
I have like a wall of all these awards and things.
All behind you for the ZZE.
They're just there.
And then you sit at your desk and they're there.
You've got so many.
You can't point the camera.
Where are you going to put them?
Exactly.
Jason, where are you going to put them in your office there?
Or, yeah.
By the way, they're in the basement now.
Will's looking behind him.
He can't fit him in the whisper booth.
I can't.
There's not one.
Why is it so dark in there?
I know.
So that his tan pops.
This is my booth.
But hang on a second.
I'm a shirt.
He's getting a nice bounce off his teeth, though.
The shorts.
I know.
Like at what age do you stop wearing shorts?
First of all.
Look at these.
Oh, it's a hockey glove.
These are special Toronto Maple Leaf, limited Toronto Maple Leafs.
When are the Toronto Maple Leafs ever had a green hockey glove?
It used to be the Toronto St. Pat's when they first started.
And then look at this. Jason, do you remember this?
I've somehow kept this after all these years.
What is it?
Is that the Wanamaker from the PGA Championship?
It's called the VH1.
Oh, boy.
Big in 04.
And we got it.
We went for arrested and somehow I've kept this stupid huge trophy.
Wait, so we got one trophy and you got to keep it?
Yeah, obviously, everybody elected.
me because they were like, who's the most deserving?
Is VH1 still going?
I don't know.
Yeah, I think so.
Hey, Sean, welcome to the show.
Yeah, question for the guest, please, Sean.
No, not at all.
Got to break in.
Let's just chit-chat.
Well, it's, you know, but it's the thing about, like,
we worked together three times,
and Will and Grace.
And by the first time, God, did we laugh a lot?
I mean, I was kicking you in,
literally, physically kicking you in the ass,
jumping in between your legs,
and, like, dancing.
like fools. It was ridiculously hilarious.
And you were so game.
And I think you're so game for so many things.
And, you know, in researching...
Yeah, too many things sometimes.
No, no, no. But, but, you know, in doing all this research before today, you realize,
oh, I don't really...
I've never done a deep dive on you.
We always have chit chat and have a good time, you know, in lap off.
You never asked her anything important.
You were just worried about yourself.
That's right. I was always like, when's the next question about me?
But so before we get into it, I just...
I just want to say, I realize doing all this stuff,
how rare your kind of drive is,
your work ethic, the ambition, the discipline.
You've been doing at such a high level for decades.
I mean, have you seen her documentary?
That documentary is just like,
I think I had a chance to run into you after I saw
and said how much I love it.
It's so impressive.
I mean, not only just well made,
but the scope of it, I mean, your career is incredibly stacked.
It's incredible.
nonstop.
And this is another thing we'll talk about later,
but the thing you do for women in general,
whether you do it intentionally or not,
I'm sure some of it is intentional,
you make them feel empowered,
you show them that talent and beauty and sexuality.
You can have all that at any age,
and you're fearless about all that.
How aware of,
are you aware of how much permission that gives people
or are you too busy working to even think about it?
I'll say this.
When I was starting out, and I had just started doing like my clothing line.
So I had been acting for a while and dancing and singing for a while,
had my first records out and things like that.
So this is, I don't know, 20 years ago.
Yeah.
And I was working with a few girls in my office who are like friends who I just hired.
You know what I mean?
And I remember saying, like it was getting overwhelming.
And I said, I just, this is so fun.
fucking much. Why am I doing this? And she goes, Jennifer, if you can't, and I probably had
just went through some breakup and fucking everything had blown up in my face again. You know what I mean?
I was just like, I just don't know if I can go on. She goes, Jennifer, if you can't do it, none of us
can do it. And when she said that to me, I never forgot it. And I thought to myself, oh,
people look at me a certain way, especially girls, like women.
Inspiration for sure
They were like
And it gave me like
A feeling of responsibility
To do things right all the time
A responsibility you like or didn't want
I don't mind it
Because I am a hard worker
And I do have discipline
Like I started running track when I was
You know
Eight or nine years old
And I was practicing every day
Like I always had kind of like an athlete's kind of drive
And work ethic
That makes sense
Yeah
And I did track for a while, gymnastics.
I played softball.
Like, I was very much an athlete before I fell in love with dancing.
Once I fell in love with dancing, sports went out the window.
Right, because it is a sport.
It is a sport.
And it was just an easy transition.
But also because I grew up on musicals with my mom and all of that.
And I loved them so much.
It was like I always wanted to sing and dance and act.
But when it took its natural time, I really, like, left everything behind and just fell in love with that.
But that really made me feel that that exchange stayed with me even all these years later because it just made me feel like, like don't fuck it up.
Like do the right things.
People are watching you for whatever reason, maybe because I was, you know, Puerto Rican and from the Bronx and came from similar places where all these people, you know, people come from.
You know, I wasn't like born in Hollywood and, you know, kind of that thing.
And so there was a real...
Jason.
A real, like, idea in my mind of, like, you have to do things right.
Don't fuck it up, you know?
And work for it.
Yeah.
And do it.
Do it.
Like, do the thing.
Like, go for the...
Go for it.
Yeah.
What was first for you?
Was it an example of someone who was just an incredible inspiration as far as their accomplishments?
Was that first?
or was it being inspired by seeing an incredible dancer or musician or actor?
When you were a little girl, what was the first thing that inspired you?
Was it accomplishment or was it a specific talent?
No, it was the arts.
From when I was very little, I remember, you bought up Rita Moreno and you bought up West Side Story right before,
as you were trying to guess who I was.
That's all he does.
And it really was Reader-Marin.
It really was Rita Moreno for me.
Oh, really?
Yes, yes.
I did want her to be my mom watching an electric company.
I said to my mother once when I was a tiny little kid, I said, I want her to be my mom.
Yes, who wouldn't?
And she's so amazing.
And the thing is, my mom watched West Side Story in the theater when it first came out.
And she made us watch it every single year.
I don't even remember the first time I saw it.
Three years old, four years old, five years old.
But I do remember watching it on TV one Thanksgiving because it came on one day.
a year and thinking that's what I want to do.
I want to sing and dance and act.
I want to dance around.
My mother was kind of that way as well and very kind of vivacious, takeover the room type
of person.
And I wasn't like that.
I was more like my dad.
I was more quiet and kind of like to myself.
But that part I had.
Like I wanted to sing and dance and shake my ass too.
You know what my mom was doing.
You just imagine you dancing and singing around like the living room and stuff like that.
Like all like kids.
kids do because like that's when we have no fear and no sense of you know and like it's like
nobody's watching you mean right but then there's that moment we all hit when we're about i don't know
10 11 or something where you start to become aware of shame and embarrassment and what other people
might be thinking and there's that transition that it's almost a sad transition that you see kids go
through where they become self-aware but then you know you hope that they gather sort of coping skills
to kind of have self-assuredness
and to kind of push through that
and have their confidence take over
and to be able to push through that.
Do you remember that moment
where you stopped kind of dancing
like no one was watching
and you were aware people were watching
and were able to push through that?
I think this is what makes me a little different.
That never happened?
No.
I was never afraid to make a fool of myself.
That's great.
I was always just like, it's fine.
I fell down.
And maybe that was part of the athlete part too.
You know what I mean?
Like it was just like you're going to make mistakes.
You're going to fall.
You're going to do the...
Like I was ready.
I'm like, get back.
Very scrappy.
Part of learning.
Part of success.
Yeah.
We'll be right back.
And now back to the show.
I was thinking about when you started and really started to sort of break through and I kind of want to get into what that was.
Because I'm not sure I really know what that thing was.
I have questions about it.
Thank you, Sean.
this is not your time.
I'd like to reclaim my time.
Jennifer, I wonder if you know,
like the moment when you broke through
and you broke through on such a global level
in such a way that is very, very rare,
where everybody in the world knows who you are,
and just bear with me,
that you have the moment where you,
that kind of dawns on you,
the level of recognition and fame,
and then you as a person,
the gap of you catching up to that
and being okay with that on that kind of a level?
Do you remember that time?
Was it a struggle kind of between you and it?
It was the worst.
It was, honestly, it was the worst.
It was, I had just done Selena.
Yeah.
And the movie came out, and I was still walking around, you know,
Hollywood, like going on auditions to it.
Like, it was still that time.
Yeah.
But it had just come out.
And I was walking down the street.
And for the first time, somebody was like,
hey hey
and they come running towards me and I thought
the motherfucker's gonna mug me
what the fuck is going on right now
like I got really nervous
and you know and I was just
you know like any woman in the world
you know we're threatened by
so many things like we're so scared
all the time in a weird way
and I was just walking
to the store from my apartment
in L.A. and
it was just so
jarring to me
And then I realized they were like, I saw you in whatever.
And I was like, oh.
Yeah.
I was like, I don't, but my thing was like, I don't know you.
Like, I don't know you.
Like, what are you doing?
Like, back up.
Don't touch me.
I was so scared.
And I remember it dawning on me.
I was like, oh, you're not anonymous anymore.
Right.
Your anonymity is gone.
Yeah.
And I don't, and I think in my mind, I thought, you can't get that back.
that's something that's lost forever
and I remember that's when I started having panic attacks
and I had oh it was terrible time for me
yeah can you talk about that when you were filming enough right
no that was another time
that was when I overworked myself
so bad when I didn't realize my limits
yeah but that I read about that
in preparation for this and that's fascinating to me
because I love medical stories
where you did you can you say what happened and why
yeah um so that was the kind of getting
used to like fame and realizing your life had changed in a way that you couldn't control anymore.
Or go back.
You can't go back.
They're always going to know, somebody will always have seen Celine and somebody will always
and for whatever reason that really freaked me out.
And that took a minute.
But what you're talking about is when I was doing enough, I think I had done like four
movies in a row.
And I had recorded my second album or something like that.
So the J-Lo album, which was really big.
Yeah, huge.
And what was like the J-Lo album.
And I was working, filming every day, as you guys know what that is, you know, all the hours.
And then I would go into the studio at night.
And then on the weekends, I, like, had junkets or video shoots or whatever.
And I remember not clocking that I had worked like 98 days in a row without taking a day off.
Right.
Because we went back and counted it because we're like, what happened?
And one day I'm sitting on the set of enough.
It's actually kind of thinking about it.
And I'm walking to the set every single time.
And every time I walk to the set, I start getting a little, like a little pitter-patter in my heart.
It's like rising.
And I go.
And finally, it got to the point.
I was like, I really feel nervous.
And I had the little girl in enough.
And I was like, I'm sorry, sweetie.
I feel a little weird today.
I said a little tired or something.
And she was like, it's okay.
You're going to be all right.
You know, she's like going like this to my face.
But I wasn't all right.
And I went back to the trailer and I sat down and all of a sudden like I just couldn't see.
Like I was almost like I couldn't see clearly.
Like something just went over my eyes and I couldn't move.
And one of my girlfriends who was my friend since the second grade was my assistant.
And she was like, so she doesn't know, like, she doesn't know it.
She doesn't really know what she was doing too much.
But we love dugging it out together and figuring it out and being together.
And I said to her, Arlene, I can't move.
I can't see.
She goes, stop it, Jennifer, you're scaring me.
And I go, no, I really can't move.
I said, no, I can't move.
You should get somebody.
And she's like, stop, stop.
I said, get B-O-B, my security.
security guard.
And she got me.
And I was like, I can't move and I can't see.
And I, like, I couldn't move.
I was just paralyzed.
Yeah, yeah.
And he picked me up and put me in the car.
We went to the hospital.
Wow.
And it was crazy.
And I said to the doctor, I said, am I going crazy?
And he said, no, you're not crazy.
It's exhaustion.
Yeah, he's like, you're, you shut down.
I remember, I remember, speaking of Monster,
I remember we were shooting a couple of days, like downtown somewhere,
and the level of attention,
I remember you having to drive to set,
and they had to put blinders on the thing for you to drive into,
and there were photographers on the roofs of the building across the street.
Yeah.
And I remember the...
And they had the base camp set up in this parking lot downtown,
and I remember these dudes randomly putting cameras under the fence
and just shooting like this, hoping to...
get somebody and I thought, oh my God.
Yeah.
That is so...
And by the way, there are a lot of people who go like, oh, well, that's the price you pay for fame
and all that kind of bullshit.
And you're like, oh, yeah.
That's pretty rough, man.
Like, you don't have a second.
Yeah, it can be really tricky.
And you learn to kind of, like, live a certain way.
Like, I don't go out all that much, you know?
And I, I...
To this day?
No where I can go.
Yeah, to this day.
And I have my, like, very small group of friends and they come over.
or we do things or we go on trips
but even when we go on trips
it's very curated
and you have to learn
because it's just
it's part of it.
Jason calls photographers
he lets them know
they have his schedule
they have access to his ICAL
they never show
and they never show
what about
now that sort of
surgical masks are so sort of like
accepted in public
and so commonplace now
do you ever enjoy that level
of you know
sort of finding animals?
I feel like people always know it's me and I feel stupid.
Like if I put on a hat like too long, they're like, it's like, is that J-Lo?
Jay-Lo?
You know what I mean?
It's like stupid.
I put a mask on.
They'll even recognize my voice sometimes if I'm not just talking in a store.
Like I'll see people creep around the aisle like they heard me talking.
And I'm like, hi.
Did your friends call you J-Lo when you were a kid growing up?
No.
No, not at all.
Not at all.
That was something that I was.
at Heavy D. I don't know if you guys remember.
Oh, yeah, because he was a rapper back in the day.
Back in the day. And we all, all the Sony artists, there was a place called the hit factory
here in New York. And all of us recorded there. A lot of people recorded there. It was a big
studio. And we'd always, people would always come in and out, you know, to other people's studios.
And I met Heavy at that time. And he was, he just always used to call me Jenny Lowe.
He's like, J. Lo! Jay Lo! Jenny Lowe. And I was like, I think, I think,
I'm going to call my next album J-Lo.
I love that.
That's so cool.
Yeah, and that's kind of how it happened.
It was really very simple.
It just stuck.
When did Jenny from the block come?
I was going to get to Jenny from the block, yeah.
It was the next album.
So J-Lo was my second album.
The first album was on the sixth.
And my third album was,
This Is Me Then.
And that had Jenny from the Block on it.
Do you know you spawned how many people in the world
probably refer to their friends,
Jennifer, as Jenny from the block.
Like, we have a friend.
Oh, my God.
Right?
Yeah, you do come across it.
But also they all do their names.
Oh, my, they people call me Ado.
Yeah, right, right, right.
Like, they put their name together and stuff like that.
Jason would be J-bah.
Yeah, you'd be J-B, J-B.
J-B.
And you're C-Hah.
Some C-Hah.
Say-ha.
It doesn't work.
But getting back to the, the,
when you were first starting,
because I think it's fascinating
that you went from the time frame
of in living color,
which was, you know,
its own story,
which we could probably talk about forever,
but in living color to Money Train,
to Selena,
at that time,
you really had to prove yourself as an actress,
and you probably worked hard to do that, right?
What did that period feel like
when you look back on it where you're like,
wait, how do I transit,
how do I get people to take me seriously
from dancing on in living color to,
to being an actress.
Well, it's funny.
My very first movie was a movie called My Family, Me Familia, which Greg Nava did.
And it had Edward James Olmos in it.
That was the very first time I worked with him.
And I played the young matriarch in the movie.
And right from that moment, I think people seeing that little piece of tape, that really
helped make the transition.
Because it was a great little role.
And I had to cross the river from Mexico.
into the thing and I'm like swimming and so I'm like I'm actiony and I'm crying with the baby and I'm like it was like a great little juicy it was a small role but it was juicy and with that piece of tape people were like oh she can act she's an actress and I was and I had worked on it before I did my first movie I studied it acting all through a and living color really bought me out to Los Angeles and that's when I started like taking classes all the time and reading all the books and doing all the things I love you did and then you did God I
remember this movie holds up i love it so much you're so great in out of sight oh my god yeah you're so
that movie is so good so so so so so you're so good in that it's such a great movie you know
really is you really dragged cloney along you know because no you did launched you launched something
you did you made cluny look good and i don't care if he hears this you made it look good and that
soda bird character and sodaberg too yeah yeah it's even too you really helped those guys yeah i really helped
No, but talk about that movie, if you will, just a little bit,
because that was like a real, that movie, like, really went like,
she knows what she's doing.
Yeah.
I mean, you already were, but.
Yeah, I was excited.
Listen, I got really lucky in the beginning of my career to work with, like,
some really great directors, Steven Soderberg, Oliver Stone, Francis Ford Coppola.
Like, I was, like, I worked with Robin Williams.
Like, there was, it was a really beautiful, beautiful beginning to an acting career for me,
for sure.
Yeah, and working on Out of Sight, it was funny.
The thing I remember the most about Out of Sight was one of the things is Steve's on,
because we had like one of the most epic nights ever singing musical theater.
I think I was singing to him and telling him I was going to be a singer, and he was like,
you're right.
I was like, I am.
I'm working on my album right now.
Like, I was so young and kind of like goofy and whatever.
But I also remember like.
the auditioning process for that.
And going, I remember the last, like, I read for Stephen, and he was like, I think I like
these talking to George.
Like, I like this girl, Jennifer Lopez to play this role.
And he was like, okay, and they had me go do like a chemistry read.
And I had to drive to George's house.
And I remember getting there and there was a pig in the front yard.
I was like, this is some real Hollywood shit.
This is some weird stuff.
And Richard Kine, collecting the mail.
He had his pig, and we were there.
And we, you know, we read like on the couch together,
literal casting couch.
And we were just had this chemistry that really worked.
And Stephen just loved it.
And I got the role.
And I was so happy because it was a really great role as well.
Did you get it there in the room?
Yeah, I think, yeah, by the time I got home,
home they had called my agent and said that you know they wanted me oh that's great how do you with with
with with so much ability um across um you know mediums how and and and anything that you basically
declare you're going to do it's going to find financing and it's going to find an audience how do you
decide what to do if if if if anything is a viable direction like i mean you could you could start a musical
tomorrow or you could do another album or you could you could finance you could start a movie you could
you could act in that movie directed that movie you could do it you could do it you could start like a
cupcake store down the street that would be come up i do have i do have cookie dough that i would think
i call j dough there you go oh for real that is the best chocolate cookies in the world and one day i'm going
i'm going to i'm going to i'm going to make this i'm going to share it with the world because you're so
but you don't sell you don't sell it yet no no that's a mistake this is this is
We can announce it today.
Leave the money on the table.
This is a big J-Dow.
I want it.
We love Chuck.
Chip Cook.
Truly, so how do you decide where to point your energy and your assets?
You know, it's funny.
You ask that question because I don't think, I think one of the things about my career and sometimes, you know, there's any long career, there's ups and downs.
You swing for the fences and you, you know, fail.
And then there's times when it's just like, you know, you just hit it out of the park.
And right now, I think I just didn't ever realize that I had that kind of power.
I always felt, again, like the scrappy one kind of trying to make it.
And erring on the side of humility and not assuming something till you're sure.
I think that's a healthy place to be.
And it did serve me in certain ways.
But in other ways, I always felt like whatever I got was good enough instead of going, wait a minute.
Is this the right thing to do right now?
Or is that the right?
It was just kind of like work, work, work, work, work, work.
I'm working, I'm working, I'm working.
And I think it wasn't just now as I'm, my kids are about to leave to college in about a few months.
They're both 18.
Don't make me cry, okay.
Wow.
I'm with you.
Yeah, and they're twins.
So they're both leaving at the same time.
It's just going to be me by myself.
And I'm looking at like what I really want to do.
And for the first time in my life, I've really taken more control.
of exactly what you're saying.
Like, what do you really want to do?
Like, do you want to direct?
Do you want to do musicals?
What have you not done that really feels fulfilling to you?
Because I actually have realized that I do have that.
That I have earned that over these years.
And I should be very, I want to be very intentional about what I do over these next four or five years.
You can take agency over your own life.
Yeah.
And also, like, give myself up.
a pat on the back, which I never did.
I never do, and I never did.
You should.
Where I go, you know what?
You created this.
That little girl would like, I always say this with like holes in her shoes in the Bronx.
You know what I mean?
I mean, I wear my sneakers down where this part of my foot was out all the time.
I'm sure that's going to be a mean.
If I ask you right now, what do you really love and value most in your life?
I'm sure that you would say your kids.
But if I narrowed that to what your career represents for you,
what is it just sort of in a pursuit of like trying to find an answer for what you would want to do next or your next chapter to be
what is it that you enjoy the most that you that your career has provided you is it is it respect is it
endless possibility yeah i think it's the that i have opened up an avenue for myself where there's an endless
possibility and i can really create a new dream right now for myself yeah for sure
And I just moved into a new house.
Like, everything in my life has changed over the past couple of years.
I moved into a new house.
What happened?
I'm kidding.
Oh, that's for another time.
It's a different podcast.
That's a different.
Right, right.
Guys, keep rolling.
Keep rolling.
You come over, we have a glass of wine.
And you come to the new house and it's amazing.
And I, like, built my little corner of the world dream house.
I've got my kids some horses.
We have stables.
Oh, that's great.
Like, I was like, please come home.
Please come back home to your horses.
There's horses here.
And just really thinking about, like, with all this change, it's actually been a very emotional time for me where, yes, I'm crying because they're leaving.
But I'm also, like, staring down, like, what is my life now?
The past 20 years, it's been one thing.
the past five years has been a tumult, you know,
and then the last two years has been kind of the healing process from that tumult
where I really got to know myself.
And the person I am today is so different than the person I was even two years ago.
It's crazy.
And now I can really look at my life, appreciate it for what it is,
and what I've created for myself, and be really happy.
and both my kids, like, got into all their colleges
and they both got scholarships
and they're going where they want to go.
And it's just, I was like, you did that shit all by yourself.
That's great.
Like, you had very little help, you know?
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
I was just going to say, I think it's awesome
that you, the way that you talk about it
and you seem so sort of clear-headed and calm,
knowing we sort of joke about it
about how much people perceive or think that they know about your life
and what you've gone through and all that kind of stuff.
And you have to kind of put that in a weird place
because people have this sort of thing that they think,
but you have to actually go through it.
And like you said, when you started,
like you're just a human being and people forget that.
You know what I mean?
It's so crazy to me because we don't really understand other people's experiences
unless we walk in their shoes.
Right.
And there's also, I think, I think, I don't mean to catch off, really, but I do think, you know, we're all, we're all aware of and some of us are friends with some people that have like this enormous level of celebrity and exposure that actually enables the ability for, enables them to stay exactly who that is for kind of as long as they want.
In other words, there's this, there's this real permissive culture around celebrity and you don't kind of have to be the best.
best part of you and you don't have to grow like you know what you just said Jennifer that you know
the past two years has been about the healing and that you're you're you're you're you're so different
now than you were even two years ago five years ago do you do you recognize that that's that that can be
a real accomplishment for somebody in your position like I think that's a real great adder boy that
you've clearly put in time and work and self-reflection and yeah could have just kind of just
kept eating the junk food of of the permissive culture around you
and just kind of lean back.
But it sounds like you're leaning into
who am I going to be for this next chapter?
Yeah.
And what have I learned, et cetera, et cetera.
100%.
I, again, there's been different times
where I felt like whether people outside knew it or not
where I feel like my life blew up in my own face.
And it was because of the choices I made,
but also because of the fact that I had things
that needed to change about my sense.
that I didn't understand or recognize that was attracting certain things and attracting a certain
type of, you know, experience into my life. And I really needed, I fight, honestly, it's that thing
where, and you can go either way, you're right, it is a choice. So I want to give myself that credit
too, but there comes a point where it's all so puzzling and wrong where you have to sit there,
And after my last divorce, I just sat there.
And I was like, I canceled my Torah and I sat there.
And I was just like, you need to fucking figure yourself out.
What is going on with you?
Forget about everybody else.
There's nobody to blame here except yourself in a certain way.
Not that people don't behave in a way that's not great.
But what are you doing?
What do you have going on?
And that was a turning point for me.
and that was a couple of years ago now.
I had the same thing about two, three years ago.
Maybe I've told you guys this in private before,
but I had a moment before I got into real therapy a couple of years ago
where one day I was making coffee in the morning
and I swear to God, and I went, I remember distinctly what was happening.
Oat milk.
Not the date.
And I remember, and I went, I said out loud to myself, it's you.
Right?
And I had this real, I was like, oh, my God, I need to do some work.
I go, it's me.
But by the way, everybody needs to do that at some point in your life.
And by the way, everybody goes through this.
I mean, it's all sort of relative.
It's part of being human, right?
Exactly.
We all have things to blow up.
We get these parents.
They do the best they can or they do as much as they can.
They form certain parts about ourselves.
And then our journey is kind of the undoing and the healing of those things,
of the patterns that that created.
And so in doing and looking at those patterns, I was able to kind of like go back to that little girl and really look at her and go, that little seven-year-old girl, like I said, with the ripped nightgown, like I can see her right now with it.
Like my hair was like up to here and it was about the same color.
And you know what I mean?
30 feet walking around barefoot all the fucking time.
And I was like, you, you, you, yeah, just thanks.
She's bad.
Still nothing's changed.
Still, Jenny from the block.
And just kind of like going, you did this.
Yeah, yeah.
You did all this.
Yeah.
Give yourself a little fucking something, like a little love.
Right.
Stop looking for love and other things.
Yeah.
And give it to yourself.
Yeah, there's so much to love in you.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And you don't see it because you're in this business and everybody's telling you're bad at this
and you're bad at that and they're scrutinizing and criticizing.
Yeah.
personal, your professional life and you're not doing this enough or you didn't choose that right
movie or that song didn't do as good as last one and you're like, and it plays on you. It plays on
those places that were reinforced when you were younger of like whatever it is the impressions
that were made on you because of the way you were loved or cared for in different ways. And it's
just, it's also intertwined. And I find it very interesting and I love it because
I really do believe people are capable of change because I've experienced it.
Same.
And a lot of that fuel for change comes from that self-love,
but that self-love is often so hard for all of us to kind of recognize and utilize
because it's hard to see because we're living with ourselves every day.
You know, you kind of get used to some of the things that you really should be taking a second
to be pleased with about yourself.
It's like you can't see.
your own hair grow, right?
Like, you see, you see, you see every day.
I also think people don't understand what it is to love yourself.
Like, to understand, to, whatever you want.
And I think having kids for me changed a lot of that because I realize, whatever I want to give
them, like, why wouldn't I give that to myself?
Right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why don't I appreciate those things about it?
Why don't I, you know, if you want respect from people, you have to respect yourself.
Those are actions, right?
Like, those are real tangible things.
And being my.
sister said to me once, Linda, who I think is so smart, and she was like, when are you going to be
your own keeper? You keep everybody else. You take care of mom. You take care of me. You take care of the
kids. You take care of everybody who works for you. You take care. When are you going to be your
own keeper? And I was just like, yeah, and these are all little pieces. I feel like the journey is
like pieces, pieces, little puzzle pieces that you fit in little as you like sit there with
the oat milk and go, it's me.
Yeah.
This fucking thing that just happened, me.
Right, right.
And you know, you mentioned the kids.
I sort of realized also that, like, that act of, the way that we love our kids, for me
anyway, my experience is that act of being loving to them allows, the reason it feels so good
is because you're generating that and then you get it back.
And it's when you close off and you don't act in a loving way pushing it.
I find the more I push out, the more it comes back.
And so, like, with my kids,
That's why it feels so good
because you're creating that
as opposed to kind of rolling up the window on it.
Do you know what I mean?
Absolutely.
No, I agree.
And the kids are a great learner,
but relationships are great, you know,
kind of learning grounds as well
where you really get to face yourself.
And if you get lucky enough to be with somebody
who actually really cares and loves about you
in the right way,
there's a lot you can learn from each other,
even if things don't work out.
You know what I mean?
But Jason, I'm sorry I cut you off.
I was just like had to get that thought out before I was.
No, no, I was kind of done.
I was just saying it's a dumb metaphor or analogy,
not being able to recognize your own hair growing
because we see ourselves in the mirror every single day,
but if you don't see somebody for a few weeks ago,
oh, your hair's gotten long.
Your hair's got a beard.
You can't really see the things inside of you
that you probably should be, you've got the greatest hair of all time.
I was trying to back into a compliment.
I know. Jason's got the greatest hair.
Do you really
fucking do.
It's unbelievable.
You know what?
Jennifer, you want to know something?
He hasn't put a comb or a brush in it since he was 11.
That's a new story.
Stop!
And he doesn't color it.
He doesn't color it.
Also true.
He's so handsome.
Guys.
You know, I mentioned it before, Jen, it's like, you know, the...
Well, maybe I didn't mention it.
I think mentioned in the intro where you left home when you were really young and you slept in a
dance studio or something as a...
I did.
As a girl.
I have done the crazy.
things. I know, but don't you look back at that with everything we're talking about now
and giving yourself and loving yourself, looking at that and going, well, I was sleeping on the
floor of a studio on my own, not living at home. And look what I've done. Like, it's just mind-blowing.
It's crazy because my mom and dad, like, I was about to start college or I had just done a
semester of college. And I was just like, I had a dream that I'm going to be in show business.
And they were like, we lived in the Bronx.
They were like, this crazy bitch.
And I was just like, no, dad.
And my mom was like, you're not dropping out of college.
You are crazy.
You know how much we do this so you can go to college and da-da-da-da.
And my dad was like, did you have a dream?
Really?
I said, Daddy, I did.
I really did.
No, da-da.
Anyway, the next few months was tumultuous.
And I wound up leaving the house.
And I kept skipping.
I stopped going to class.
college and I was going to the dance studio and literally taking class all day.
I just so fallen in love with it.
I was, yeah, I wanted to be a lawyer.
I worked in a law office for a few years during high school and I was like really good
with numbers and taxes and things like that.
I don't know.
I was just good at it and they loved me.
And I just on this track to be a lawyer.
And I was going to apply to law school, whatever.
I don't know.
Anyway.
Yeah, I mean, it's wild to know that, yeah.
Yeah, it didn't happen, and I decided to, like, go sleep on the dance.
I needed somewhere to go when me and my mom had a big falling out.
And I called the dance teacher, and I said, you know, can I come stay?
I'll sleep on the couch at the dance studio.
And he said, yeah.
That's crazy.
He liked me, but yeah.
Do you still have a talent for numbers and bookkeeping and that types of things?
Like, are you involved with your?
Or do you just kind of just let you just...
No, I'm smart about it, but I...
And I've always been very attuned with my biz managers,
like not to let my money get away from me.
But you're not like playing the markets and like, you know,
looking on the stock pages and like...
I do some investing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because like some people I know, they really like,
they handicap companies, kind of like horses
and they really follow that.
Yeah, no, I don't.
I don't.
But I, and I left that behind and probably can, you know,
do multiplication. Now, my kids' math
is too hard for me when I try to help
them. You know what I just read the other day?
They should be good.
The keeping tree?
A page of a book?
They don't teach cursive
anymore in school. I haven't done
for like the last few years. I know. Why is
that? Well, I guess because typing
is such a big part of... We don't write anymore.
But you've got to sign your name and stuff.
Exactly. Like, what is a signature?
They teach them their name in kindergarten, I think,
and that's it.
And that's it. We're done.
Next chapter.
How's everybody's handwriting?
Self-assessment on your handwriting.
Oh, it's terrible because you don't get to practice it.
The worst?
Jason Badge.
My brain works faster than my hand, so I can't, you know.
I also want to have to write a birthday card.
I'm like, it's horrendous.
Wait a minute.
Like, I have to cross shit out.
It's crazy.
Do you do all caps?
I do like a hybrid.
It's terrible.
Yeah, me too.
It's a hybrid.
Yeah.
I'll start every sentence in cursive and then end up going,
just for legibility.
alone. I want people to understand what the hell I'm writing.
It's so true.
Okay, so this is like, I'm going to just because we're almost at a time with you.
Speed round, speed round, speed round, speed round.
So we're going to do like a little tiny something speed round.
If you, if you, we didn't even get to your like, to your music career, which is just
massive.
And I've been to, I know every other song that you've ever recorded.
And I just think it's incredible.
I mean, what you've accomplished.
You know, it's pretty insane.
I just had a number one dance record.
Like a few weeks ago
Yes
I had a new record out
Called Save Me Tonight
And I went and I performed it at Coachella
And after that I went to number one
That's amazing
It's amazing
It is amazing
Had you done Coachella before?
Never
It was my first time at Coachella
Was it was it a freaky big experience
Or was it
It's massive
It's big
And it's I had never been
I didn't know what it was like
Or whatever
But you have all these people
And I hadn't done a dance record a long time, and David Getta had this record.
And I was going out on tour last summer to do like a little limited tour overseas.
And I was like, I need some new songs.
Like I'm tired of performing the same whole songs.
So I did like five new records.
By the way, we're not tired of this song.
Thank you.
I still do them.
I did like five new records, three or four, yeah, four or five new records.
And I put them in the show.
just for that.
And this one kind of popped off.
And so we released it a couple months ago or something.
And what about videos?
People still make videos, right?
They do.
But it's not the same.
Yeah, I don't really even feel like I need to sometimes.
Do you have to pay for them?
I do.
Yeah, because it's different.
Like when I started, they'd spend millions of dollars on videos, like a million dollars,
$2 million dollars with big budget videos.
You know, Michael Jackson, Jan.
used to do like $7 million videos, you know.
But now, because of streaming and how the record business has changed since I started,
it's like a whole different world.
You have to shoot them on your iPhone, yourself, $100,000.
Sometimes they give you $75.
It's really a different thing.
And that's to promote the album that you have a...
Probably through social media, too.
Yeah.
Right.
And it's not even your album.
It's the labels album.
And the way the music industry runs nowadays, correct me,
most of the income for the artist comes from touring
as opposed to album sales.
Is that right?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Now, speaking of touring, you've done,
you two it forever.
You didn't obviously massive, massive shows your whole life.
You know I love horrible theater stories.
You might not know this, but give me something
that happened on a tour that just went horribly wrong.
That's funny.
Well, I don't know if you saw this.
Oh, yes, I know what you're going to say.
I know what you're going to say.
The thing on my net.
Did you see it?
No, I saw it.
when you fell.
No, that happened.
But that wasn't on tour.
That was on television.
Oh, that's right.
And it ran on CNN for the next three days.
My fucking coxics was fucking on fire.
Right.
It was just like, it was awful.
But no, I was going to say this summer on tour.
I was.
I just wrote three jokes.
Sorry.
I'm not doing any of them.
There's a coxics on fire and we need to take pills for it and all this.
Never mind.
Yes.
This summer when I was on tour,
I don't remember where I was.
Oh, God, which actual date it was.
But I was there and I was, I might have been in Spain
because I was singing a Spanish song.
And it was like the slow moment in the show, you know,
although usually I'm dancing around and doing the choreography
and like a fucking bikini and a G-string.
Right? Right.
Whipping my hair around and it's a good time.
And so I'm standing.
Same, same.
Yeah.
And so I'm standing.
there fully dressed and I have this thing on. It's like outfit on and I'm singing and it's really
quiet. It's just a spotlight on me and I don't know like all during the show I was seeing like
little bugs and things around but you know we're outside. Oh this I did see that. They're attracted
to the light. Yeah. And so everything is dark except for me and I'm singing and as I'm singing
and as I'm singing the audience starts screaming and usually they do react in this moment because
I stop and it's a slow song and they usually clap and whatever before I do the little last
line. I do like a dramatic pause. But this time they're like clapping a lot and screaming.
And I was like, what's happening? And I'm just there. And this huge bug is just crawling up my neck.
And I feel it. And I thought it was hitting me and going away and hitting me and going away.
But when you see the thing, it's just, it starts like down here and it just goes.
Yeah.
And it lands up right here.
And I just feel it a little bit.
But I was, I just stayed really still.
And I finished the song, the last line.
And then I just go.
And I kind of go.
And it flies into the light like that.
And I saw it.
I was like, what the fuck was that?
Yeah.
It looked like a helicopter.
It was crazy.
I love that.
But that was crazy.
But it was kind of horrible.
Like if I would have known it was that, I probably would have just screaming and yelling.
No, no.
Okay, three final little things.
What's the most Bronx thing about you
that's never left a matter where life is taking?
I can't stop cursing.
I try.
Okay, great. I love that.
I have potty mouth.
It's terrible.
I love it.
And then, by the way, I'm telling you know this, Jen already,
but I'm saying to Jason and Will,
did you guys know that Google images
is because of Jennifer Lopez?
What do you mean?
That Google didn't have Google images
until that green Versacee dress.
And then everybody Googled it.
So then Google's like,
we don't have anywhere for people
to see images. A search engine. So they invented Google images
because of Jennifer Lopez. Isn't that wild? And Sergey, Sergey has
you know, that he's been asked that after that. He's like, yes, that is absolutely true.
Jennifer, when she walked the red carpet in that dress, everybody wanted to
have a picture of it and we didn't have any Google search picks anything.
So we invented it.
Sue them, sue them. They're so rich. I was like, don't I deserve some money for that?
For sure, for sure. We got some good lawyers.
Okay. And then we got to do.
Got to plug this because I can't wait to see it.
Office Romance comes out June 5th on Netflix.
It does.
Yes, you, Brett Goldstein.
He wrote it with you in mind.
Yes, he did.
Super funny, Brett Goldstein.
He's funny, but I love his brand.
His brand of writing where it's like really kind of hard jokes,
but with this wholesomeness at the end of the day.
It's just, it's really, I think you guys will like this one.
Okay, good.
I can't wait for guys and girls, not just the romantic comedy for like girls.
And then this is really cool.
Edward James Olmos, who was your dad in Selena, is your dad in this movie?
He is.
And I got to tell you, when we filmed with him and he walks in on this, like, board meeting.
And it's the first time you see him.
And when he walks in, like, all the cast and all the extras that were in the board meeting were like, you know, kind of like, he has such a commanding presence.
But even more than that, when we screamed it for the first time, and he walks in and his first line is hot.
damn with that really deep voice and people just started clapping in the theater and i get
and i think part because he was my dad and selina of course but also because it's just like
it's edward james almost you know um and it was great it was great to get to work with him again
he's amazing and speaking of musicals i love kiss of the spider woman i can't believe it was your
first movie musical ever you need to do more and second of all are you i read somewhere you're
going to do bye-bye birdie but that was a while ago that was a while ago that was a while ago that was a while ago
Do you remember when they were doing like these musicals on TV?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
The NBC.
Are you asking if Sean remembers?
Yeah.
I did Hairspray live with Ariana Grande.
That's right.
So when they did those,
when they were talking about doing bye-bye birdie,
but then it kind of went away.
Well, make it happen again.
I don't know.
We'll see.
You'd be great, Rosie.
You'd be a great Rosie.
Trust me, I practiced all the songs.
Well, they could change it to everything is Jay Lo.
Yeah, they could.
They could.
All right.
Well, honey,
thank you so much for being here.
You guys are great.
Thank you so much.
It was very cool of you to do this,
Jennifer.
Thank you so much.
No, not at all.
Ever since you did it that one day
and I walked into the podcast,
I was like, I've got to do that one day.
That's right.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm sure you're off to go do something.
What are you doing in New York?
I was doing the up front.
Right now I'm editing.
I'm working on an edit for the,
I just did a residency in Vegas.
and I did a new show, a brand new show, the J-Lo show, which you would love, because what I did was
combine my hits with musical theater inspirations of mine. I know it sounds like it wouldn't
work, but it worked amazing.
Wait, but it's a, it's a residency where you just...
So we filmed it for Paramount Plus and for CBS, and so I'm editing, we're editing that now.
I can't wait to see that.
Yeah, we filmed it.
Yeah, that's good.
Very cool.
Busy as ever.
Just doing my thing.
Keep going.
Singing, dancing, show, girl.
It's really so impressive, Jennifer.
It really is.
Keep going.
Thank you.
It's amazing.
You guys are so kind.
Thank you.
Yes.
We'll see you soon.
I'll see you soon.
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
Bye, honey.
That's a big star.
Sean, that is a massive, massive talent and star.
I mean, when I was reading about her, it's just, you go, oh, yeah, oh, wait, yeah.
Oh, wait.
You know, that's not a star.
That's a, that's a mega star.
That's a mega star.
That documentary is pretty stunning.
I mean, it takes you all the way through it.
Everything that she's done.
Who can do, who does all of it?
Yeah, yeah.
But it's also so incredibly well earned.
It's not, it's not because, you know,
there's some sort of celebrity manipulation or something.
She's like, she does everything and does it at such a high level.
And people are, you know, paying for it.
And they're supporting it.
And she's just...
And she has this sort of, as I was saying,
like this sort of, this coolness and this calmness
and this, like, knows who she is clearly, right?
And it's, like, so comfortable.
And again, I was kind of getting at that thing
of, like, we all think that we know.
Right.
And who people are.
I remember watching...
Remember that Tiger Woods documentary came out a few years ago?
Oh, so well.
And it started...
And I remember turning it off because I was thinking,
like, I don't think he wants me to know all this stuff.
Do you know what I mean?
Oh, right.
I just turned it off.
I don't know all that stuff?
But just anything about people,
when any people just talking shit,
like we don't know anything about it.
Oh, I thought he was in it.
I thought you were saying it.
No, no, no.
Until we hear from them what their experiences,
we don't really know.
And she does seem so purposefully aware of her beginnings,
of her roots,
and is constantly staying in touch with the people
that she surrounds herself with.
Yeah.
And so that's probably what she's so on it.
Shawnee, I mean, that was a great get.
Oh, I'm so happy.
And there's no way you would be lazy to work in the bye-bye birdie thing at the end there of your questioning.
I didn't even thought about it.
No, no.
Plus, I think you've used by-by-burty before.
Many times.
Yeah, I would never use the game.
We'll just wait.
We'll wait for something a little bit better.
Yeah, I know that you need a Google search or something.
Yeah, if there's something that needs to come up, you know what I mean, that you had it thought of.
Well, the bye-by-by-Burdy thing is real because she,
She was going to do it.
No, we know it's real, but maybe if there was something...
You can't set yourself up like that.
No, yeah.
You know what I mean?
There's got to be something typing and just trying to think.
Well, you guys know from her album, This Is Me?
Sure.
Yeah, of course, yeah.
Oh, my favorite.
What do you...
You mean her 2002 record, This Is Me?
Yeah.
This is me then, yeah.
And you guys know...
This is me now?
Yeah, this is me now.
Yeah, this is...
You have a favorite song for that album?
Yeah, it's so good.
It's called.
never it's called never a good
bye
you sneaky son of a
bye birdie
oh
you are so bad
smart less
smartless is 100%
organic and artisanly
handcrafted by
Rob Armjarf Bennett
Barbacob and Michael Grand Terry
Smartless